[Music]
it's timeless it's like biggie it's like
air force one it looks like a planet
saturn it's history and i think if you
really want to
taste a piece of history you come out
here this place opened
over a hundred years ago i feel like
i've traveled through time
we're walking into jg melon we're in the
upper east side this looks like an
average irish bar
but it's burger mecca everything is
beautiful
mahogany old world green gingham
tablecloth and then boom this thing
arrives
in front of your face you put on uh me
for sure the first two
and that's about it pickles for sure 100
all the time i love that they do the
cottage fries still instead of
fries guys guys it's like ruffles on
steroids yeah word that's a very good
explanation
i think i'm going to take that first
bite just naked oh i just want to eat my
feelings like a cathy cartoon
oh my gosh
it's amazing it tastes like a steak in a
bun
and every time i come here i'm amazed
because i see
one tiny griddle they're doing so many
burgers i think like 600 burgers a day
it blows my mind that they can keep the
thing hot enough to get a sear
this well it's incredible this is damn
near perfect this is like
a 99 pointer feel this is the form
upon which the new burger place is
freestyle
[Music]
all right gentlemen we are at the region
we're in roscoe village in chicago and
uh
this i think is illinois and indiana's
greatest contribution to the burger
gastronomy
okay this is the smash burger now i know
that
it's big at shake shack and steak and
shake but
this takes the smash burger to the
extreme and so
the beef here as you can see is that
it's not just smash but he takes a
a trowel like like what a bricklayer
uses and it compresses it it's like a
piece of chip like a potato chip yeah
it's a
beef crisp the smash burger is probably
my favorite style of burger
amazing all right try this wow
the edge perfectly seasoned this is
a smash burger turned up to like mach 5.
tell me step by step how this thing gets
done first you're cooking your patty
and it's like coarse grind so you get
that steakier
chew to here to your meat you're searing
your patty beautifully
you've got your bread brushed with
clarified lugra butter so you're
crisping that up and the cheese goes on
and you're overlapping slices until it's
hanging off the edges a bit
then as it melts it hits the grill and
starts to crisp up throw your scoop of
onions on once your bread's ready
right put the whole thing together and
then we're always about sauce on the
side here
you know i can't wait to dig into this
look at that flapper
[Music]
it's just red
[Music]
the onions are low and slow super sweet
there's that swiss cheese
frico chip
right there whoa dude that tastes like
cheese chicharrone
yeah it's exactly and you have one of
those like the maserati of griddles
right like
it's a griddle underneath the griddle
the crossfire broiler two drawers
they move up and down there's a flame
across the top there's flames underneath
right so you're always heating it from
both sides not only is it pretty
yeah but it's [ __ ] powerful [ __ ] yeah
where it hurts we are far outside of any
city forget dallas we're
far outside of any city far outside of
dallas we're in the rolling hills of
north texas right now because you always
seem to take me to places where
i feel like i traveled through time you
did try with the time
you traveled back in time this place
opened over a hundred years ago
it's still in the same family family
owned burger joint in texas
fourth generation this burger is a
primary source program this burger goes
back to the beginning
of the hamburger age the method is
unlike anything you've seen it has a
big wad like two pounds three pounds of
ground chuck on the flat top that's a
mountain of beef
and he carves off what he needs for a
patty smashes it with a trowel
and that's it man i can't i can't wait
to try this
[Music]
oh right that big fish oh
there's so much going on and such a
little burger
part of the flavor i think from this
burger comes from the fact that there's
a like a 60 plus year old griddle over
there yeah but danny is fourth
generation
family member okay family owner what
he's doing over there is
100 method how many burgers you think
you've made
since you've been working here oh i have
no absolutely no idea
come on there's no way to know anything
i
i wouldn't even know what to guess i
count the money in the door at the end
of the day and it's never enough
[ __ ] like a true restaurant
we're in los angeles we're i guess like
in like
your church i have a few churches out
here but this is one of probably one of
the most important ones right
yeah they're the keepers of a tradition
they're keepers of this tradition of
taking a burger wrapping it wax paper
and just slap it in front of you right
that's really all hamburger culture
should be about apple pen is
my favorite burger spot
[Music]
i'd say in the world whoa yeah i mean
like
what is it about this place that makes
it like a bucket list spot
one of like the mount rushmores of
burgers in this country the burgers the
apple pan
are important because they actually hold
the key to la's hamburger history
it hasn't changed and that's the most
important thing is there's nothing new
about the place we've got the hickory
burger
and we've got the steak burgers right
they look similar right but they're not
at all they're not right it's
wrapped and put in the envelope yeah so
it actually stands up straight which is
there's no no need for a plate no knives
no no no napkin enough just served like
that
classic la style which i love is it's
loaded with lettuce it's loaded with
all kinds of veggies in there look at
that you got mayo right you've got
pickles on there also and you've got the
sauce
it's good to know that places like the
apple pan exist right it really gives
you hope that you know the hamburger
culture is alive and well
it was awesome 30 years ago and still
hot as [ __ ] today
oh but for meat cheese and bun burger
show baby
don't get it twisted i'm still eating
after they wrap cut this [ __ ]
what's up everybody thank you for
watching the burger show make sure you
hit that like button
make sure you smash that subscribe
button hit that notification bell
if not for me for the burgers thank you